Syrian government forces in the suburbs
of sera kept hours before the strategic
town fell after fierce fighting with a
Syrian rebel defenders sera kept sits at
the junction of two major highways and
was seen as a major obstacle in
regaining control of the province
one-third of which is now under Syrian
government control turkey has warned
Prada Mascis forces to back off never
unfortunately the Syrian regime does not
believe in political process and thinks
peace can only be possible by a military
solution and I have to say they are
wrong about this they have stepped up
their aggression Turkey has 12 military
observation posts positioned around at
live de-escalation zone agreed with
Russia and Iran in 2017 but nine of them
have been surrounded by advancing Syrian
government forces to protect Soraka and
stop the advance turkey established four
more posts which ended up in direct
clashes between the Turkish and Syrian
army's the attacks were responded to
within the scope of self-defense from
now on any kind of attack will be
responded to appropriately and our
observation posts will continue their
duties the Syrian government has
intensified its attacks since last
November and backed by Russia has
targeted civilians this triggered a new
wave of migration with hundreds of
thousands of people fleeing the violence
in the nine-year long civil war in Syria
it was aware that this place could find
refuge but ellipse city center is now
under threat as the Syrian government
forces captured Soraka and just seven
kilometers away senebkay sólo al Jazeera
Bab al-hawa northwestern Syria